my name is rachel levine i'm the bible
administration's new secretary of covet
and many young people aren't wearing
their masks because they don't think
it's lit
but i'm telling you right now you can
turn up and have a great party even with
your masks on
and i'm no stranger to partying i love
jellies and buttons and
black beauties abyssinian tea candy
tranqs
circles erasers wolfies jellies maggies
valleys eggs school bus i love a little
aunt nora french fries liquid x blind
squid
cat valium green jazz special k super
acid african salad herbal speedball
electric kool-aid sugar cube purple haze
yellow sunshine big chief
cactus san pedro alice boomers caps cow
patties
fungus tweezies yellow fever velvet
skittles triple c
magic mint and bath salts so listen kids
your new health secretary isn't an old
fuddy duddy i like robo tripping as good
as the next person okay
the safest thing you could do is wear
your mask
get vaccinated and then let's [ __ ]
get this party started right also after
a short battle with covent 19 the
president of the united states joe biden
has passed away